I mean TJ Fletcher was not just any
fraudster he ran a fraud Empire that was
taken down last year in British
policing's biggest ever fraud operation
the court heard today that three police
officers had spent 700 days
investigating the operation with help
from International Partners including
the FBI including Dutch police and in
total the website I spoof that was run
by Fletcher had defrauded people of
around 100 million pounds worldwide 43
million pounds of which was here in the
UK although prosecutors told the court
this morning that actually really those
numbers are only estimates based on the
best investigative work that police were
able to do and the true costs to people
right across across the globe may never
be known essentially what I spoofed the
site did is it gave criminals the tools
to impersonate Banks so that victims
were called from numbers that looked
trustworthy looked like they belonged to
Banks and then use those that that
technique was used to calm them
essentially out of money people were
asked to transfer enormous sums tens of
thousands of pounds one individual lost
two million pounds in just such a
transaction and Fletcher for his part
was paid millions of pounds in Bitcoin
117 Bitcoin totaling about just over 3
million pounds given to the site in
total of which just under 2 million went
to Fletcher personally and when he was
arrested by police last year he was
fined in possession of a Lamborghini of
two Range Rovers and of a Rolex watch
with a total value of over three hundred
thousand pounds in spite of the fact
that the judge said told the court this
morning that he had no known legitimate
sources of income and victims had
reported their businesses failing as a
result they'd reported depression
sleeplessness they'd reported breakdowns
in family relationships the judge said
that the experience for them had been
harrowing and that is why she has
imposed such a large sentence of 13
years and four months TJ Fletcher
himself had expressed some remorse in
fact he'd written a letter to the judge
saying that he was sorry that he hadn't
fully appreciated the full impact of his
crimes on the victims at least until
he'd read the victim impact statements
but the judge was very clear
she said in her view that his regret his
remorse was more regretted having been
caught than any true remorse for what
had happened to his victims